have you ever found yourself feeling
trapped unable to progress in life
stuck in an endless cycle of repetition
that drives you mad
but you can't seem to break free from it
you wake up in a cold sweat after that
horrible dream where you're being
strapped to a chair and tortured by
muppets again
you walk to your computer and log into
twitter which is ironically very similar
to the dream you had
and then you see more comic book news as
the talk of the town and you realize oh
god damn it i have to make a video about
this so everyone will stop asking me
about it all the time you open up google
docs tears in your eyes and your pants
soiled your hair turning gray at 23 and
you realize you are in that negative
space between happy moments in your life
you're a slave to the borderlines
forming the perimeter around the good
times
you're a useless piece of refuse lying
dead in
the gutter space the one internet news
show where the host has been dead the
whole time
so anyway a bunch of new dc stuff
happened at e3 but for dc dc dc dc let's
start with patman and his lighthouse
with a bat stuck in it i for one think
this movie looks indescribably cool i
love the visual style with the depth of
field being used to create a huge
contrast between characters in the
backgrounds pattinson looks like he's
owning this role and batman's walking
through automatic fire and clubbing
people with his namesake what a badass i
still can't believe that's bullseye
under all that makeup too there's not
much to say other than that i'm excited
oh god i gotta get the riddler trophy
how did i even collect that it's a
liquid
wait
that must be the riddle
i need the bat funnel
in other batman news at the batman
announcement show we have gotham knights
where batman is dead and the court of
owls are terrorizing his various
sidekicks
hey i'll let you in a little secret see
you see that guy you see it yeah that's
that's batman right there he's fine he's
fine that's him they're gonna unmask him
and be like oh no batman we gotta save
him he's the talon now and then it'll be
a boss fight of everyone trying to pin
him down to administer the antidote and
it'll be like that resident evil 5 boss
you can't kill batman off he's too
popular what do you think he is
nightwing
whoa
crack
dick slips on a banana peel and his
bones shatter like mr glass
talk or i'll crush every bone in your
body
[Music]
but yeah this game looks neat i guess
it's a little strange not to have it
connected to the arkham universe
considering the last one ended on
the setup for this one almost but they
won't be bogged down by continuity the
old character designs and jason todd's
character being ruined to [ __ ] you could
even have the joker show up again since
he's not dead in this world i'm not
saying you should i'm sick of the joker
please god no joker for like a little
while at least
speaking of the arkham universe suicide
squad pushing continues starting out
with some recreations of old arkham
asylum imagery in the opening
i love the retcon that this is the real
deadshot and the white guy batman fought
for over 10 years was just some copycat
and like
the world's greatest detective never
noticed or commented on it
or apparently fought the real guy
like okay you don't want people to be
confused because he doesn't look like
will smith so you redesigned him a
little bit i get that
oh this is kind of bizarre
should i just change the design and just
like not acknowledge it who cares it's
[ __ ] this video game so this game
looks fun and interesting and i love the
character designs of the justice league
the sense of humor work for me and the
premise is interesting however i have a
problem with the title either the title
is misleading and they're not going to
actually kill the justice league just
set them free from brainiac's mind
control
or
they're going to massacre the [ __ ] out
of all these beloved heroes
which i don't want either i don't want
superman to be an evil murderer and then
i use a kryptonite shotgun shell to
paint the wall with his brains
i want to just like
play as superman but that'll never
happen he's not popular right now he's
not batman so it's kind of a catch-22
from the looks of it not every member of
the justice league has their head in the
brainiac zone because wonder woman looks
normal and is trying to stop the crazed
superman
there's a shot of a batmobile but i feel
like it'll probably be just damien wayne
or dick grayson as a fake out since
bruce isn't hiding after he got
cancelled on twitter by scarecrow that
one time where he was too lazy to escape
from being strapped to a table
like a dumb [ __ ] maybe this universe
should end with brainiac killing
everyone because this place sucks now
more batman
the flash and also the flash go hang out
with michael keaton batman
the batman cinematic universe
the flash costume isn't the worst but it
needs some refining i feel like the
forehead on his cowl is too bulky and
gives him this weird neanderthal look
at least he's not wearing a spray
painted old batman costume like that
joke on twitter oh hey wait a minute
what's that guy in the back there got on
when dwayne the main vein insane in the
membrane got cast as african-american
adam i was worried that he wouldn't be
playing the character he'd be playing
dwayne johnson in a black adam costume
and they'd make black adam more
charismatic and sympathetic but in this
teaser it appears he's introduced by
murdering some innocent guy and everyone
describes him as being a ruthless
monster so it appears my fears were
alleviated it was weird that near the
end of the trailer though uh that black
adams started talking and he transformed
into a cartoon dog and kevin hart showed
up i thought that was a strange choice
but i i don't know maybe it'll make more
sense when the movie comes out there's a
catwoman anime movie and it looks cute
i'll check it out i don't care about
aquaman 2 whatever the first one sucks
dc really [ __ ] the bed with that casting
[Laughter]
shazam 2
shazam
no trailer but we got some damn cool
behind the scenes stuff
and like a little bit of footage i dig
the new costumes and the new look of the
villains i like the first one a lot so
i'll check this out i hope they can film
the third one in time before the cast of
child actors looks exactly like their
super selves
gotta inject some puberty blockers into
these guys or stuff they're getting huge
just like burt ward would have done
hollywood's very scary children please
avoid it at all costs
peacemaker looks fine kind of going for
a more silly murdery feel like deadpool
so the dc cinematic comic book movie
universe of comic book films continues
to have some really nice variety because
shazam was like a john hughes family
comedy thing and peacemaker blows up
people's heads and shows his wiener
probably except it's invisible i like
how peacemaker and vigilante's costumes
are as honest of an adaptation as you
could get from the books
they really didn't change these designs
at all and it gives them so much more
charm and color to contrast with a
darker tone and excessive violence
transversely the flash tv show is basing
all of its marketing on a pair of yellow
boots because what else do they have at
this point
if you wanted to impress me maybe he
should have like worn them from the
beginning
instead of it taking a decade
and because marvel or petty little piss
babies who wanted to be in a gutter
space episode real bad
they released some new stuff the day
before fandom on em too like spider
versus new title
and uh some no way home set photos that
don't really show anything and uh some
hawkeye stuff and the secret password to
kevin feige's personal hat closet which
is said to be slightly larger than the
warehouse from indiana jones
thank god all this stuff came out so i
could talk about it because these other
videos are taking a while and ben and
jacob won't go see venom 2 because
they're lazy
so we can't make a video on that yet but
we got plenty of cool stuff coming down
the pipe let's go back to the 90s
[Music]
you